but because of
the rules on youtube we said well you
know what it's not rigorous enough until
we have more to add to it so there were
two exclusively pediatric studies to be
clear now i've got the va and it comes
on the heels of two pediatric studies
these were published in may found that
40 to 45 percent of all pediatric
hospital admissions were cases where
covid was incidental meaning they were
being admitted and you can go to
lotterathr.com right we have the link in
the description you can go read the
sources that means that they were being
admitted for something else like cancer
or a psychiatric episode which by the
way these have increased because of
quarantine isolation people aren't going
to school and they happen to test
positive for covet that's again 40 to 45
percent wow
covid was incidental they didn't even go
because of covet or have symptoms that's
insane everyone gets a covet test if
you're admitted right now in the
hospital are you saying locking kids up
and making them wear masks and scaring
them is somehow hurting them
psychologically no